[Musique]
je m'engage à faire tout ce qui est mon
pouvoir et dans mon pouvoir pour
renforcer la relation indispensable
entre le Royaume-Uni et la France
et aujourd'hui je vous invite à vous
joindre à moi dans cette affaire
ensemble notre petite ciel est-il limité
un engagement les uns envers les autres
et envers les valeurs que nous partons
suffisamment
un engagement inspiré par l'exemple du
passé et on corrigé à relever les
immenses des filles du monde qui nous
entourent
c'est pourquoi nous devons sérieux
et entretenir notre ententeudiale
renouvelons là pour les générations
futures afin qu'elles deviennent je le
propose également nous entendre pour la
durébilité pour reprendre plus
efficacement à l'Agence mondiale en
matière de climat et de biodiversité
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
plus de 91 depuis que nous ne sommes pas
tous côte à côte pour la libération de
l'Europe nous faisons face encore une
fois à une agression injustifiée sur
notre continent
[Musique]
notre détermination et notre alliance
sont plus importantes
importantes que jamais
on semble nous nous tenons aux côtes de
peuple ukrainien avec une solidarité
résolue
[Musique]
ensemble nous sommes inébranlables dans
notre détermination que l'Ukraine
triompha et que nos libertés si chers
[Applaudissements]